- Get ready for that puke shot.
(upbeat music)
- I'm definitely not a nutritionist,
but I care about what my
kids eat and what I eat.
- We get a calendar every month that lists
the breakfast and lunch
that she gets at school,
and it looks good.
- I remember the cafeteria
lunches growing up
being really bland and dry.
- They tasted like cardboard.
She's in the same school
district as I was, so
hoping they improved.
- I'm sure it'll be some
sort of combination of
processed and heated foods
and then maybe like a
token vegetable or fruit.
(upbeat music)
This is a substance I'm not familiar with.
Can somebody tell me what this is?
- See?
Blob.
And it smells like nothing.
- Nothing.
Just tastes like beige.
- Seriously, this is
what they give at school?
- It says fruits, grains,
vegetables, protein, dairy.
My only question is is
if this is what we're
supposed to be eating,
does this chicken salad
sandwich reflect that?
(upbeat music)
- I'm not excited about this.
Not at all.
- This is definitely
like a microwaved moment
right now, I can tell.
- Oh, it's so gross.
- This sandwich looks like a scrotum.
- The meatballs look like they can bounce.
- This tastes like it was
prepared maybe a month ago.
- I can plug my nose when I try it, right?
- It bounced.
- No one's seasoned this obviously.
This is like tiny water
balloons in my mouth right now.
- It tastes a little dish watery.
- Very sad corn.
- Where did they find this?
Did it fall off a truck or something?
- I would probably just eat these.
(upbeat music)
It's like a shoelace posing as meat.
- Very pliable.
- Aren't they supposed to be orange?
- Why can't I pierce it
past a certain point?
- Pretty bendy.
- Is it really an egg?
- That is disgusting.
- I don't know what this
ham meat is supposed to be.
- I wouldn't give that to my dog.
- How is that meat?
That's rubber.
- Almost a fifth of
the entire day's sodium
in this one packet.
- That's so bad.
How do children eat this?
It was actually way worse
than I thought it would be.
- Everything felt a little rubbery.
- I'm really worried that
this is what I depend on
while I'm away from her.
- I just think about the
kids who don't have access
to meals and this is how
they're gonna eat lunch,
and I'm just kinda bummed out
because this is what we're
offering them, and I think
we can do better, and we should do better.
(peaceful music)